China is the All-Seeing and listening
state
surveillance cameras are increasingly
fitted with artificial intelligence
including facial and Iris recognition
technology meaning pictures can be
analyzed in real time
today the average Chinese citizen spends
nearly every waking moment under the
watchful eye of the state says the
co-author of a new book there are more
than 400 million cameras surveillance
cameras in China there are close to a
billion smartphones rallying around in
people's pockets and purses that the
Communist Party can access
during the often turbulent rule of
Chairman Mao Zedong people were
compelled to read his little red book an
iconic work that contained his
observations but China's current leader
has much more
an app an app that promotes Xi Jinping
thought
just one of the many technological tools
that help create a cult of personality
around president XI as well as
strengthening ideological control over
the ruling communist party's 100 million
members so the kindness party believes
that if they have enough data and they
combine that with the right tools they
can essentially predict human behavior
and mold it to a degree that they can
engineer a perfect Society right and
this is a you know this is a sort of
future society in which there are no
dissidents
the government says its surveillance
Network helps maintain order and reduce
crime it's co-opted some of the
country's biggest tech companies to
track phones monitor online purchases
and decode messages certainly with the
Advent of new technologies and Chinese
companies becoming Giants in in areas of
surveillance technology for example and
facial recognition
um China certainly has used that the CCP
has used that to its advantage and
implemented that in China
covid-19 brought even more surveillance
for most people everyday life like
taking a bus or entering a restaurant
hangs on the color of a health code on a
smartphone but already evidence has
emerged that some local government
officials have been using the app as a
tool of social control Adrian Brown Al
Jazeera